for this past year everyone's been  asking me the same question what will  change in the NHL franchise when it  finally comes to the ps4 and Xbox one my  answer almost everything starting with a  new generation of hockey player one that  comes alive with intensity athleticism  and emotion NHL 15 will also give you  more control than you've ever had to  embarrass your friends and truly create  those amazing highlight reel goals we  put physics on all 12 players and the  puck bringing a new level of toughness  and unpredictability to every game you  play and Beyond the ice NHL 15 brings  the energy of the sport to life in the  most detailed arenas we have ever built  this is the beginning of a new  generation of hockey and on behalf of  the team back at EA Canada I'm extremely  proud to give you your first look at  actual gameplay in motion this is NHL 15  you